[Music]
did you see that Twitter like it was a
viral tweet it's like my date didn't
care that we were all girls bowling with
him and the dude like is fully just
trying to slam strikes no yeah and then
so a girl quot tweets and she goes as
soon as I see your little leg kick out
to the side I'm out like who Do You
Think You Are the dude replied did that
I am no it was just a picture of
him I like godamn godamn wait so the
dude was doing the kick out like that
yeah yeah yeah so like it's an original
video of a girl recording D rock yeah
recording her dude dude's rock man yeah
it it was like okay her home girls okay
and he didn't give a [__] he's like I'm
here [__] I'm going to steamroll all
so he was with like five girls yeah and
he's
just
just knocking them down yeah I love that
yeah you got to do it yeah you can't be
[__] around you know no can't be
letting people win I can't get a Leen at
a bowl because she's not good at it and
she said she hates walking back after
hitting two pins yeah she just can't
it's like legitimate cringe for her she
can't stomach it I did read that on like
an ick list yeah like some that some
girl your daily updates daily ick list
yeah yeah yeah top 10 icks for Monday
yeah yeah thank God I'm clear daily
email news newsletter that I'm a part of
here are your here are your daily XS for
Monday October 10th um one of them was
like when guys walk back from doing a
bowling shot and I'm like [__] and they
miss I don't I don't it was just when
they walk
back cuz I think that is kind of an
awkward thing but I think that's that's
why you have to be serious yeah but even
then it's a little bit ick you think
maybe a little bit I don't know if
you're like
yeah suck
it you'll be like all right it's just
bowling calm down you know I don't know
man that kind of turned me on I like
that I don't know that [__] was kind of
hot man yeah yeah I don't know man it
got me kind of horn honestly so I don't
know bro I'd [__] yeah what's the
biggest beans eating beans wait can we
see can we see that list oh what the
hell eating beans eating beans bro to
the list I see isn't that your whole
country though okay what is this don't
have a hobby don't fall over I mean
that's that's definitely it don't tie
your
shoes don't get cold don't walk downhill
this has to be like irony right yeah
these are all things that people have
said in videos that he to the video so
so he like at the end he'll like he'll
Stitch one and then just like scroll
down to the bottom and be like don't eat
beans right okay got it so you can't run
down a hill yeah
know yeah running down a hill cuz dudes
do this
like right like when you're on the hill
right right like right don't but I don't
get that don't walk down a
hill yeah oh CU it looks icky no I'm
sorry I'm reading this yeah so it's it's
from a guy's perspective he's making
this list he's watching this these Tik
toks and be like okay I was reading this
like this is direct
quotes I see yeah yeah yeah like just
picturing it English like when you don't
walk down a hill oh I see yeah yeah so
he runs do they all run all right don't
walk down a hill yeah don't be born on a
certain month or listen to country
music don't have a
birthday don't get
cold don't fall over makes sense don't
say both so
cold don't say both is don't
bathe I just that was my dyslexia sorry
I just made up to
say I'm [__] still say both the
biggest beans eating beans eating
beans she's adamant about it too she
said it three [__] times she's been
waiting for somebody ass that there's a
beans saw finally eating beans dude
there's a trauma there yeah yeah
yeah man
you think you think she may had an
experience with a gentleman and right
immediately after he just rolled over to
a can of beans yeah she's like oh that
was so great he's
like straight out of the
can got to get my macros lock lot of
calories from
that damn
biggest what's your big yeah I want to
see I want to see a scous person doing
this what's your biggest e
click that guy's
account is he he's the same guy that
does all of them yeah he does just click
one with a lot of
[Music]
views
being all right this is all very tongue
and cheek right like we're all in on it
yeah you know like when a girl posts
that we're in on it yeah and then when
he does this we're in on it everybody's
laughing I yes I I actually think some
some of these are real though no for
sure but I I think what's or maybe this
guy isn't in on it I don't know but I
think what's crazy now
is we used to be able to do this right
women be like men be like and it was
fine yeah I think there was like a
mutual understanding that okay we're all
in on it we're all doing be likes right
now but now you do this and just you
know the stitches are
like this is women bro yeah yeah yeah
and then that becomes like you see how
men are and it's like
dude can we just do a little women and
men be like just just a little be like
it's fine we're just doing a little be
like right now we do be like that yeah
men do be like this when men and women
do be doing yeah yeah but you know now
it's just you know I missed the time
where we could all just be a little
stupid yeah and we could all just get in
on a little be like I wish that we yeah
I missed the times where we could be
like yeah because now yeah cuz now you
can't you can't even be like no you
can't you can't can't if we if you and I
if we be like if we be like about let's
say you know a dumb husband be like okay
if you know if we play in that we laugh
at ourselves then you know someone's
gonna be like see man they're
emasculating men yeah yeah it's like no
dude I just I don't remember [__] in the
grocery store that is truth it's just a
joke we're [__] around yeah yeah and
if you if you if you do be likes you're
soft you're stupid you know you're not
hitting hard enough yeah it's like man
when yeah does everything have to be so
like serious yeah so you know that's
you're spitting right now honestly you
are
I I feel that I just you know 100,000%
just missed the days where we could all
just be like be like I want to be like
again yeah I miss King
Batch he's he's on Tik Tok he's there no
I'm just saying like the old days like
the be like days you
know some of those are are some of those
were sort up racist yeah and aged pretty
terribly but you know I just mean the
more nuanced stuff yeah when a comic
would get on stage and they'd go like
man yeah my wife be like
and I be like yeah you know I'm stupid
yeah you know everyone's like can have a
soft
chuckle